it was Russia not Syria that broke the
news foreign ministry spokesman
Alexander Lukashevich announced it in
Moscow salut 13 work maturing story as
pleased to announce that Damascus has
expressed its readiness in principle to
participate in the international
conference conveniences of the Syrians
themselves can find a political path
towards solving the conflict which is
destroying both the regions and the
countries to lead you on the conflict
Russian Foreign Minister Sergey Lavrov
increased the pressure on Damascus in
the past days he's discussed details
with a Syrian government delegation like
who Damascus should send to the peace
conference the opposition Syrian
National Coalition is currently debating
strategy in Istanbul the Exiles want to
know more about the terms of the
conference and we would like to know
that this delegation is empowered to
make decisions including the transfer of
power to this interim government daily
transitional government that is fully
power to make decisions meanwhile the
Syrian regime is using the time it has
to continue its campaign government
troops continue to attack rebel
positions supported by Lebanese militias
you